this little baby yep young Penny looks
exactly like we would have imagined in
this picture though we would have
pictured her wearing something a little
more Penny like pink perhaps either way
we can definitely tell that this little
cutie with her pretty blonde braids was
surely as popular at age three as she
would be in season 1 of The Big Bang
Theory when she was 21 years old penny
is of course played by the famous Kaye
kuoko and while this is the youngest
we've ever seen Penny many of us have
seen kuoko fairly young too but may not
have realized it quok played Connie
Reinhardt in the 1992 TV movie quicksand
No Escape quo was only seven in this
role and yeah we can totally see this
being her a few years earlier as for
Penny she was once an aspiring actress
but back in kindergarten she was
sticking to puppet shows